yeah sam first of all uh tell us a
little bit about the format of this uh
event is very new and exciting what how
do you feel about it um so of course if
you ask like 20 different players what
their favorite format would be you get
20 different answers and while
if i just got to pick exactly the format
myself and then i got to play the
tournament that's not a luxury anyone
ever gets but if i got to pick it this
is not what it would be but it's darn
close
it's closer than anything i've seen and
so i'm a huge proponent of knockout
tournaments
i think the by far the most successful
individual sport is tennis and well i'm
not a huge tennis fan as far as i know
essentially every single serious tennis
tournament just knockout and uh i think
it's a fantastic format and i'm really
happy to be finally playing a big
knockout event with some best players
all over the world from here in st louis
and tell us a little bit about this
specific matchup between you and
dominguez every single game you guys are
playing it seems like it goes on a long
theoretical battle 20 30 moves of theory
how did you approach this match yeah so
i mean i had a little bit of time to
prepare for him so i think probably the
format doesn't suit him as well just
because he's um he seems like crazy well
prepared and just plays his normal stuff
and says come at me find the best stuff
you have and
if you have 24 hours to prepare for him
uh it's pretty real chance he's just
gonna prepare you but uh even if he just
plays his normal repertoire but if you
have two weeks it's a little different
um no i mean i
i got more of a sense of him as a player
i i've learned a lot by losing to him in
us championship when i got some slightly
better position with white i saw tons of
end games that were slightly better and
thought basically black is holding them
and eventually one off the deep end just
went too crazy trying to kill him and
then when he drew his other 10 games in
the tournament i felt like an idiot but
um no i think i have a better sense of
him now um but
it's one thing to have a better sense of
players under beat him he's obviously
very strong and so you know we'll see
let's take a look at the game tell us
when did your preparation finish
so i i definitely had bishop d2 but i i
wasn't remembering everything uh super
clear i thought i remember thinking
bishop g5 was
the most testing of after um
after king f8 i remembered i definitely
reviewed bishop g5 this morning and i
know i have analyzed bishop d2 yeah so
here queen e2 king f8 i'm pretty sure
bishop g5 is most testing i reviewed
that this morning but
i i know i covered bishop d2 but i
couldn't remember very well so
uh after i'm pretty i'm 90 sure knight
g4 is right maybe even 95 percent
because i i remembered after queen f1
knight e3
take
actually in this position i think knight
x h2 was recommended uh by the engine
going into the line of knight xh2 take
on h2 rook to e5 or rook to e4 yeah
i saw this as well but i thought that
knight e3 was
i'm pretty sure i had knight e3 as well
as as equalizing um
but so he took it rook e3 and i know
that for example rook d1 is a draw after
rook f3 and knight f3 and
queen g2 queen h2 forever so um
but yeah knight g5 came and i was a bit
foggy on the details i'm actually pretty
sure what i played does not equalize
that i remember thinking that this
uh queen take queenie this rook this
queen takes g5 and and queen e7 was not
supposed to equalize but i was shocked
by bishop takes up seven i thought here
absolutely everything was a draw like i
just couldn't find a way for me to even
screw it up after
queen e7 bishop f7 like i was also
thinking like if i go queenie for check
and then he goes king g1 and rookie two
i guess the big point was bishop d5
chuck
uh and after this
rook f2 bishop b4 rook b2 i still
thought this was almost certainly drawn
after say like i thought like i don't
know bishop b7 rook c2 or something and
he's you cannot possibly tell me he's
going to beat me with his rook on a3
like i i thought this was basically a
draw and then also after rookie two
queen f3
i thought rook takes h2 was a draw as
well so
uh
i i didn't think i would lose this end
game after king h2 queen f7 so i thought
absolutely everything was a draw my sis
i think the rookie three is most direct
there was
just one detail that um
was important to see that there was this
funny line that if
we go queen f4 maybe i can even play g5
but i was thinking rookie four five
point five rookie five queen h7 and here
i was calculating some nonsense where i
go king f7 rook f1 king e6 and ron and i
didn't see a win for him even there but
there's this nice idea i can go rookie
one check
knight f1 and then king takes f7 and
this move order he doesn't even get any
checks in here probably white is worse
because he runs out of checks after say
queen f5 king g8
so as far as i can tell it's just a dead
draw after bishop takes f7 i think he
should have tried rook g1 but this just
seemed very easy
sam thank you very much tomorrow with
the white pieces we're looking forward
to that game i'll do my best
thank you sam
absolutely